I will never use the metric system at
least that's the title of a video I just
made every time I make a video there are
loads of things that don't make it in
there's just too much information out
there I mean look at this so here are
five things that did make the cut the
word jiffy is an actual unit it's the
equivalent of approximately 1 60th of a
second be there in a jiffy Napoleon
isn't actually short like everyone says
he is he was just mismeasured because he
was the guy who was around while the
metric system was sort of being adopted
by France and there was just a
misconversion blah blah blah because the
United States teaches both Imperial and
a little bit of metric in school it is
estimated that a full year of math
instruction is lost to the duplicated
efforts of learning both metric and
Imperials which is why the United States
ranks 38th out of 71 countries in terms
of math skills there is a freeway in
America that only uses metric signs look
at this I went really deep into the
whole story as to why this all went down
it is pretty fascinating and at the end
of the day kind of sad I wish I used the
metric system but I can't